really good really good yeah yeah very
very excited um I have like three most
useful things so I don't know what what
that counts is but I think you have like
firstly you have preparation like I
learned a lot about the preparation
process in a video which I previously
did actually consider I used to think of
people with their shaky cameras I didn't
actually have an idea of what they're
doing but most of the time they probably
had a storyboard and it's not like by
accident and then eventually becomes the
idea of iteration so you have to keep
keep trying different scenes many many
takes and never never came to my mind
and lastly like you have to have the
passion for this if because you would do
a lot of takes you'll be pretty sleepy
after a while but you pretty you you
love what you're done and I'm kind of
excited to show what I have yeah yeah I
guess the hardest part is there's so
much content and there's a lot of
technical stuff that I wish I knew like
I wish I knew more about the the
creative suite and like the software so
i guess i was a limited in that
department but other than that I think
the preparation part gives me that
background helps me to do a lot of
different things yeah yeah thank you